[SOUND].
Hey there, I'm Matt. One of the instructors from the
course Tales from the Genome. I'm really excited that you
logged on to learn with us. What do you say
we get this genetics party started? You mind loading the course?
[SOUND].
Welcome to Tales from the Genome. And
adventure in DNA, identity, and health. I'm Matt.
>> And I'm Lauren.
>> And together, we'll be your genome guides. Now, I have my PhD
in cell and molecular biology and I'll be your main instructor for this course.
>> And I have my Masters degree in experimental psychology. Matt approached
me to help him teach this class because I know a little bit
about genetics through psychology, but I
always want to learn more, and I thought
this was a great opportunity for me to learn about my own genome.
And help you learn about yours.
>> This course should be accessible to anyone of almost
any age or any knowledge base. If you're still in high
school, or even if you already have a graduate degree. If
you find yourself taken a lesson, and the information in it
is a little too basic for you, feel free to
jump ahead or skip around. You can use the syllabus to
find out which portions are most relevant to you as a
good starting point. Together we'll discover the secrets of your genome.
>> And,
reveal a new perspective of what it means to be human.